ça fait des jeux des jours que ça dure
des producteurs agricoles au québec et
un peu partout où ils sont allés
d'ailleurs on vous en parlait la semaine
dernière devant la colline parlementaire
à ottawa pour manifester leur inquiétude
et bien c'est arrivé les 12 pays de
cette zone pacifique ont bel et bien
signé un nouvel accord de libre échange
qui prendra je le souligne de c'est
quand même un détail important qui
prendrait un certain nombre d'années à
se mettre en place il faut d'abord que
chaque pays
en terrine fasse voter cet accord là on
a évité un et visinand vous le
connaissez chroniqueur radio économique
bien connu vous êtes d'ailleurs le matin
chez nous maintenant re division
bonsoir à vous on va écouter un extrait
du représentant des producteurs laitiers
du québec mais avant j'ai une petite
question pour vous est ce que le canada
avait vraiment le choix
oui ou non d'aller danser avec tous ces
pays note d'accepter quand vous avez
vous principaux partenaires économiques
qui disent on va se réunir ensemble et
on va discuter de la suite des choses et
on va être une douzaine pour voir
quelles sont les prochaines règles et
que vous iriez non moi ça m'intéresse
pas je reste n'a pas fait ce que vous
voulez moi je m'arrangerais ensuite
d'être par la suite il va y avoir des
relations qui vont être établies et là
si vous levez ahmed al fois j'aurais
voulu y est ça peut être plus tard dans
les faits le canada n'avait simplement
pas le choix
très bien on va parler des gardiens des
perdants après on le fait un peu
rapidement avec gerald tout à l'heure
mais je vous fait écouter donc bruno le
tendre eux sont très déçus aujourd'hui
les producteurs laitiers parce que on va
faire entrer un peu de lait étranger un
peu de volaille étrangères on écoute on
a donné 2 % à l'europe
pardonne 3,25 à chaque fois qu'on a
entendu des libres charme on sait les
poteaux de l'expert on entre on donnait
déjà 8
d'accès au marché jose 2 avec l'europe
plus trop
on commence à être assez élevé le
d'accès au marché terre qu'on soit taxée
de près tout voir à l'importation mais
pour le lait qu'est-ce que ça va changer
au québec par exemple si cet accord est
mise en vigueur de même atteindre mais
les producteurs ont produites pour au
moins 25 % moins de lait qui vont dans
la transformation que ce soit dans l'est
de consommation dans les formats raw
d'albert ses 200 millions à la ferme au
canada de moins de production presque
autant dans la transformation donc c'est
des pertes réelles
on n'est pas content
rené vézina vous allez devoir se désole
nourrit expliqué la gestion de l'offre
on protège ou maximum 6 3 production
dans les yeux la volaille et le contrôle
de la production contrôle des prix et
contrôle d'un origine des produits qui
nous sont servis donc il ya quand même
un mur de chine autour de manière à
stabiliser nous dit-on les prix mais
c'est aussi pour préserver le statut des
producteurs n'existe plus ça n'existe
plus ailleurs dans le monde et en
passant si je peux faire quand même un
commentaire le problème le plus
important des producteurs de lait du
québec actuellement le cpo le 3.25 qui
va entrer sur le marché
c'est le vieillissement de la population
les fermes laitières diminue rapidement
on est vraiment perdu beaucoup beaucoup
parce qu une population vieillissante
consomment moins de produits laitiers et
donc ça déjà c'est un problème majeur
nathan ils vont avoir le nouveau qu'il
va avoir cette petite brèche de produits
venus d'ailleurs mais actuellement un
producteur du vermont par exemple qui
veut exporter son legs re il le peut
migrer des tarifs douaniers tellement il
est élevé ça crée un mur ça crée un
muret en fait c'est infranchissable
longs ont créé cette petite brèche est
d'ailleurs là il ya quand même une
inquiétude légitime monde à partir du
moment où vous avez cette petite fissure
est ce qu'elle va finir par s'élargir en
passant c'est quand même 300 millions de
dollars par année à peu près là c'est le
4.3 milliards sur 15 ans que le
gouvernement fédéral va verser en
compensation pour les revenus qui
pourraient être moins ça c'est important
non il y aura du
et qui vient d'ailleurs un peu peut-être
plus de volailles dans le jeu est ce que
le prix de litres d'huile de lin qui est
très cher au québec va baisser au
pinacle est plus cher qu'ailleurs ça
m'étonnerait que ça baisse
vraiment il pourrait y avoir un peu de
compétition par ailleurs et c'est pour
ça que le président de l'uds pire
monsieur marcel groleau lui donner moins
de jeux de mots ils marchent au 10e
actuellement parce que pour ceux qui en
perdent et qui voit venir une
concurrence il ya quand même beaucoup de
productions je pense qu'aux producteurs
de porcs qui vivent le marché asiatique
imaginez si le canada on n'avait pas
fait partie de cet accord
si on laisse carrément les américains
foncier dans le jeu de quilles par
humain le marché japonais le japonais et
en passant l'indonésie la chine ne font
pas partie de ces discussions mais tôt
ou tard ils vont devoir embarquer donc
c'est immense le potentiel là ça devient
une question d'efficacité qui est en
mesure de produire un coût abordable et
avec la réputation que nos producteurs
ont d'assurer la sécurité de ses
approvisionnements qu'on ne sort pas
n'importe quel produit avec des normes
qu'ils soient soient plus basse qu'à ya
donc ce fait la balance des avantages et
des inconvénients vous vous êtes d'avis
que c'est un accord qui était d'abord
incontournable pour le canada il savait
qu ici on propose y est et c'est
toujours une question de compromis et on
ne parle que de l'agriculture mais vous
permet aux gens dans le domaine de
l'aéronautique on sait à quel point
c'est important dans la région de
montréal je voyais un communiqué émis
par ces six là avec ses simulateurs de
vol 93 % de sa production est exportée
l'on vient de lui offrir encore sur une
plateforme la possibilité d'investir ces
marchés dans le domaine de la
métallurgie des produits forestiers
bref ça va être comme sur une balance
avec deux plateaux
il faudra voir de quel côté ça va pas
chez davantage moi je pense qu'à terme
canada est un pays exportateur on
n'avait pas le choix dit donc sur le
mois sur une échelle de 1 à 10 par
rapport à l'aller n'a à l'époque si tout
si important c'est plus important plus
important c'est qu'à rope l'année nancy
l'état déjà important d'ailleurs l'alena
demeure avec les états unis le mexique
mais là c'est vraiment l'ensemble de
l'asie qui s'ouvre tranquillement à
commencer par le japon qui est nos
partenaires et avec qui on voulait aller
davantage c'est le vietnam qui est une
économie émergente cc l'astre
lycée la nouvelle zélande si on leur
donnait le change l'australie eux ils
ravagent un des marchés qu'on aurait
voulu investir la sous location de voir
de quelle façon on a pu le faire moi
c'est dommage pour les producteurs
laitiers on ne les abandonne pas ils ont
droit à des compensations et ça va
prendre quand même un certain temps à
être mis en application
rené vézina très clair merci beaucoup je
vous en prie à la prochaine